This video was sponsored by blue apron purveyors of fresh ingredients and quality recipes delivered right to your door
I've put a link in the description so you can sign up and get fresh food delivered to your house
And if you're one of the first hundred today, you'll get three meals on your first blue apron order for free. Hey
What's up guys and welcome back to another random?
Experiment with thermite now to give you a little context in this video a couple weeks ago
Jimmy Fallon's team reached out asking if I can come up with some new summer life hacks
Now being a Youtube mad scientist the first thing that came to my mind was seeing if we could light off a grill with thermite
And actually cook hot dogs and hamburgers
Now unfortunately lighting off the thermite in the studio is one thing that Jimmy Fallon is not allowed to do so for this video
I thought let's put it to the test anyway and see if barbecuing hot dogs and hamburgers
Or thermite is a viable option after all here's the basic idea behind our experiment today
We have two metallic powders iron to oxide and aluminum powder these are very very fine powders
And when we mix them together in the right ratios we create a batch of homemade thermite the burning of thermite is an extremely?
exothermic reaction releasing temperatures upwards of
5,000 degrees Fahrenheit
So we'll start the reaction by putting the mixture in a terracotta planter pot setting it on top of the grill and letting the Molten
Iron flow down into a Terracotta base plate down below when the bottom plates are full of Molten thermite
We're going to remove the Terra cotta pot stick on some hot dogs hamburgers and using the residual heat of that metal we're going to
See if we can actually get them to grill
All right, our bachelor might is mixed up for ready to go?
So we're just going to transfer it into this terracotta planter pot sit on top of the grill and let it off
So we got a blowtorch a sparkler for our time delay. Let's go ahead and light it up
fastest way to let your barbecue ever
There you go
All right, here goes let's see if it works
Come check this out. This is amazing. So we got the terracotta pot on here which I'm going to promptly remove
Looks like a little bit of our grill kind of gotten bolt in there and look at that bottom plate
You can see how all the thermite stripped down to the bottom and now we've got a plate of glowing Lava as it were
Just sitting down there at the edge. I can't actually pull this grill off. Oh yeah there goes
Look at that. That is unreal
Now right now. I think this is way too hot to put our meat on
I think this is actually burn the meat. So we're just gonna let it cool down for a few seconds
Did you see the way that that lid off and all that Molten metal flowed down to the bottom?
That's the reason I had this little terracotta base and even that
It's cracked into a bunch of pieces
But it has managed to keep everything one place and not burn to the bottom of our width you look at the planter pot on
The other hand this thing is so hot right now
It's actually scorching the sand that I was setting it on it's broken into pieces and there's all kinds of vitrification
Happening on the inside the other thing I noticed is we actually burn the little hole through one of our grill racks here
But that's cool. I'm just going to go ahead and replace that now
Stick that on top
Yeah, look at that you see how that melted right through that's where the thermite was dropping, and it just melted that clean off that
Was a superhot reaction that was fantastic
And it's actually going to need a few minutes to cool down before we can put our meat on here
So while it's doing that take 10 seconds right now to drop down to the description and click the link for Blue apron?
You might remember blue apron from some of my previous videos?
I've worked with them before and their food is
Fantastic and definitely approve here's how it works a box shows up at your house with all the farm-fresh ingredients
you need in
Exactly the right proportion can make delicious chef's design recipes at home the box is refrigerated so the ingredients stay fresh even if you're not
a home when the package arrives and they deliver almost
Anywhere in the USa there are two different types of plans one that feeds two people and another that feeds four and because the recipes
you make our chef's design if you follow the directions your meals are to be great a lot of times when I
Go first for shopping always buy a lot more than I need and trying to spending more to spend in the stores
So this save that money
blue Apron adds new dishes to their menu every week and each one can be put together in around 40 minutes or less and if
You use me as an example
I don't really know how to cook and I've never looked at this recipe before it only took me 45 minutes start to finish
I was so shocked that my husband was in the kitchen cooking. That's the first time I've seen it is very
Different Mary Ten Years
You can skip or council your service any time you feel like and shipping is always free
So take ten seconds right now to drop down to the description click the link for blue apron and get something delicious and nutritious
On its way to you this week all right back to the barbecue. Let's take a look at the slow-mo replay
So it looks like I caught the slow mode just as the reaction was really starting to take off and you can see it's glowing
as bright as the sun
Which makes it very hard to see what's happening here now the iron oxide is reacting with the aluminum to produce a lot of heat
It's putting off a lot of light energy
the way you can't see happening inside is all that Molten metal inside the pot is flowing down to the bottom hole cutting through the
Grate and landing in that terracotta dish underneath. I have to say that's probably the most dramatic way I've ever started to barbecue
That looks absolutely fantastic
What I can't get over is how bright that reaction is it's so incredibly bright that you can't see anything else is taking place
For the light that's coming off of that kind of looks like peering into a volcano nothing, but glowing Molten is fantastic
And probably the coolest way to cook food on set that looks amazing if I were to do that again
I might use a second terracotta dish underneath, but it looks like it contained all that at the bottom
Great all right go ahead and put on some hot dogs
Listen to that sizzle
So we have eight hot dogs on here
We've got three hamburger patties
And it's already starting to smell amazing
So I'm going to go ahead and put the lid back on let's wait about 10 to 15 minutes and see if there might in
Fact is able to cook our food
All right, it's been 20 minutes. Let's see we got oh
My goodness that looks gorgeous
absolutely
looks really good it smells delicious do
These and give him a little flip those are juicy, huh? Oh
That was good
There we go very nice very nice the little cheese on that. We go make your cheese burgers beautiful
today's couple men
Who would ready that looks so good?
oh
nice and juicy smells delicious
mmm
That is really good these things are absolutely ready fantastic
Here we are guys. We've got our hot dogs are hamburgers and everything is looking and smelling amazing
I can't believe we actually pulled this off. We started by mixing iron to oxide
Which is basically rust with aluminum powder and lighting off inside of a Terra cotta plant suspended over a barbecue
We use the residual heat from that
Exothermic reaction to go clock dogs and hamburgers to perfection and now it's time to eat them. We've got our hamburger
We've got melted cheese onion pickle tomato lettuce and all tops with a sesame seed bun
Let's eat as much as I want to try this myself ladies first
I'm going to go let my wife have the first bite here you go baby. What do you think? Oh it looks good?
I'm always up for a good meal
You have to give us your honest opinion
Take nutrition. Let's take a look inside there
Let's show them the inside of the hamburger there you see it actually did cook it cook all the way through
What you weren't sure it wasn't question you let me bite it I?
Was pretty confident?
Lee go take a look at this you see you got the meat in there. It's fully cooked if we break that open
Yeah, you can see it's cooked all the way through nice and juicy
absolutely delicious bon appetit
mmm
That is one delicious and juicy hamburger that's definitely one way to put a little iron in your diet
So there you have a guy's no more waiting for charcoal to get ready
We have just used iron and aluminum powder to make the world's
Fastest starting barbecue ready for cooking with in about a minute and a half hurray for science
Hey, thanks, so much for joining me for this experiment today. I'll be looking for in the next one. Talk to you that
Hey guys quick reminder
There's a link in the description right now to sign up for blue apron if you're one of the first 100 people to order you
Get three meals off your first blue apron order for free please enjoy responsibly
That's the beautiful piece of tomato
This knife is not very sharp
Alright guess what we get?
Hey guys, there is an event called CVx live that. I'm going to be at august 3rd through 5th stage presentations meet and greets
There's even a special superfan experience
But we can hang out one-on-one, so click the link in the description and I'll be looking for you at CVX live
*End Of Video*